welcome to the world of rage kill an
unprecedented partnership in gaming rage
to uses its software's best-in-class
first-person shooter mechanics with
Avalanche Studios mastery of open-world
insanity
incredible combination of action and
scale plays as a smooth and seamless
experience completely free of load
screens set 30 years after the events of
the first game rage 2 takes place on an
earth that's begun to recover from a
global catastrophe life is returning to
the planet in the form of diverse and
awe-inspiring bio from jungles to
deserts to wetlands and more the world
is springing back to life your character
hails from Vineland a secluded Conclave
that you're forced to abandon after its
attack by the newly resurgent Authority
you start in the secreto wetlands where
you've been sent to find dr. kvasir
fans of the original may remember him as
your helpful ally in true ed style your
character comes equipped with a sizable
arsenal of powerful weapons
and making it struggle to return a fan
favorite the win stick which has new
tricks in the game that will show off
for you in a bit with your 30 Newton's
out of the way let's talk with dr.
kvasir he called 15 it was never
deployed and remains in orbit around the
earth
I simply need you to travel to the Eden
Space Center and call it down from orbit
yes I forgot to say it might be overrun
by bandits the goon squad to be precise
the goon squad is just one of several
factions on counter and raged to hyper
violent and completely lawless the goon
squad leaves a trail of destruction in
their way the immortal shrouded on the
other hand are a group of elite bandits
with access to incredible tech bleeding
- mighty vehicles weapons and cloaking
ability you also have the river
the Abaddonn mutants the authority and
more to contend with each faction has
different settlements combat styles and
sweet rides vehicles their people part
of branch and to make sure to double
down there's a mind-blowing assortment
of charged up chopped up and jacked up
machinery to drive in and contend with
you've got whiplash inducing racers that
will leave your opponent's spitting dust
formidable roaming enemies and wheels
from every faction and as if that wasn't
enough there's also the threat of
massive convoys with their insanely
powerful convoy leaders there's so much
more to find and ride there's a convoy
near you headed to that barrel carrying
an explosive payload
make sure you don't forget the Hellfire
monitor
the Phoenix is an all-purpose
rolling Rube Goldberg of pain
oK you've arrived at the Eden spaceport
which is currently overrun with goon
squad but not for long because you've
got an entire arsenal of powerful
weapons gear and abilities to help you
deal with this threat abilities like
black
as you take down opponents your
overdrive eater will fill up when the
meter is full you can unleash overdrive
Siculus Display of power that pushes all
of your weapons past their limits and
even unlock special abilities for each
one in addition to your collection of
upgradeable weapons and gear there's the
new and improved wing stick enough
created wing stick and target and kill
enemies even around corners
unauthorized personnel are no longer
present threat has been nullified made
it to the control room now bring down
that EcoPOD
Terkel sequence approved
here you'll get access to a brand new
ability shatter a fierce blast of
kinetic energy
time to test out your new ability on
hell yeah
beware the massive mutant crusher you'll
come across many mutants like this
throughout the world of rage to better
stay on your toes or you'll get crushed
the wide open world of Rage 2 is
bursting at the seams with weapons
vehicles and over-the-top action thank
you
quick look at what you can expect we'll
have even more insanity to show off in
the coming months
[Music]
crash she cries she cries crush